shawn mendes seemed to be living his
best life in lockdown so
while he was in toronto for a while he
did some social posts but being in
toronto
clearly from his latest instagram post
he's gone down south because the weather
looks
much better than it is in toronto he's
definitely not drawn on that photo yeah
so
he posted this photo look at that photo
oh just love him
his caption is grateful the sun
coffee my health my family
old mariah carey songs music
humans oh so granola
now you make me think where is he right
now yeah now
who had to post her own response to that
mariah carey of course
so she did a similar pose and wrote
grateful the son
t my health my family old sean mendez's
songs
music humans then sean
took the trolling a good find he
commented on mariah's post
with a hahahahaha and a heart and a
crying laffy emoji
that's it's funny mariah carey's whole
new like social media
i don't know what you want to call it
but like her post that she's like very
much like
the knowing very much like jumping on
like trends like remember that christmas
decoration
that looked like nothing like girl like
she's very much and we're seeing a few
artists like this now that are really
like i think of obviously um
uh dion warwick who you know came
twitter yeah
really seems to be jumping on like
whatever's like happening
to be like hip on instagram yeah and i
think that's probably because she has
kids
the kids are in the know right so
they're like mom you know what you need
to get on tick tock mom
you should do this trend mom you know
and i think that's part of it the fact
that she's
she she likes shawn mendes music you
know uh you know
it shows that it's probably the
influence of her kids i'm being
influenced by my kids too
so uh you know maybe that's what it is
but you know i love mariah carey i love
the way she does her social media it's
always fun it's always
you know something you want to interact
with but uh let's see if she starts
doing more tick tock challenges too
i know i realize i love the trolling by
mariah carey hilarious
yeah that's the thing like she really
seems to be embracing the trolling ever
since
that jennifer lopez thing became a thing
if i don't know her she really seems to
be jumping on this like
yeah yeah this thing of like oh like
other artists are doing things and kind
of like
poking fun at them a little bit like
this is all good fun she's not really
yeah
like yeah making fun of shawn mendes
anyway but no it's it's super special no
she's not
yeah awful says no oh hell yeah mariah
carey's troll skills are top notch
uh marty says i love when artists love
on one another some positive stuff is
great
yeah so random for sean mendes to say
old mariah carey songs like
not that mariah carey songs aren't great
just random for some minutes
to choose maybe it's maybe they're gonna
collaborate maybe
this is a sign of them coming together
maybe this is the way they're announcing
it yeah charlotte's is the perfect
response with the perfect picture
yeah for sure yeah totally fun yeah it's
nice to see those kind of moments i love
it